malines lei ok aujourd'hui comme il est
apparu sur des représentants ce qui
semblerait être un hélicoptère de
l'armée américaine faisant feu sur les
journalistes s'en aille douze millions
de personnes ont vu cette vidéo et tu
veux le faire croire qu'il s'agit d'un
site sans importance
ceux contre qui nous luttons ont des
hommes de l'argent et des armes
moi tout ce que j'ai c'est un site web
tu veux vraiment changer le monde
ça exige des sacrifices cette banque
abrite des milliards de dollars sous des
compteurs revin et malgré cette fois
l'ancien pdg de la plus importante en
geek landaise a été accusé de fraude ce
qu'on a réussi à faire oublier pour
glisser le truc de fou le courage est
contagieux
aujourd'hui la maison blanche a révélé
la fuite de 90 mille documents
militaires
on risque une crise internationale
majeure sont à nos trousses il faut
publier maintenant c'est la plus grosse
fuite d'informations confidentielles de
toute l'histoire
si on avait eu quelqu'un comme vous le
mur de berlin serait tombée des années
plus tôt
danger des fontaines d'informateurs il
ya des vies mises en jeu ce n'est pas un
journaliste c'est une menace à la
sécurité nationale
car pour a été négocié tout élément sens
tout tu dit pour retenir surtout tu
voles faut écraser ses mains ce sont des
informations que le monde doit
reconnaître si la queue de publier le
times à venir si vous voulez la vérité
je devais la chercher vous même ce dont
ils ont peur d'eux